[Music]
on this Tuesday night ramping up the
supply of critically needed personal
protection equipments extraordinary
measures are required in these
extraordinary times what two billion
dollars will buy and where it's coming
from
calls to relax rules for renters this is
going to be hard on everyone as the rent
is due and debts pile up America's
soaring death toll the grim milestone
the u.s. just reached plus kick-starting
the Keystone XL pipeline project the
lifeline Alberta is banking on during
this crisis and coronavirus questions
from kids how long should I go tour
friends housing grandma's house again we
will ask the experts
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we know so many of you are working day
and night to help in this pandemic and
there are lots of developments tonight
we have news about more protective
equipment and test kits on the way but
for some perspective let's start first
with the worldwide picture the number of
confirmed cases of kovat 19 is now fast
approaching 1 million about 20% of cases
are in the United States which still
leads the world in confirmed cases
180,000 and Counting
more Americans have now died of this
virus and died in the 9/11 attacks and
even President Trump now says April
could be a deadly month and as the cases
soared so does demand for personal
protective equipment or PPE we know some
hospitals in Canada are already
rationing things like masks that it's
burn rate how quickly it's being used is
far higher now than usual because of the
risk today the federal government
promised two billion dollars is being
spent to buy more public services and
procurement Canada is aggressively
buying in bulk from all available
suppliers and distributors to date we
have ordered millions of swabs gloves
masks and other vital equipment we will
need more masks ventilators and testing
kits but how many more we need depends
entirely on you the situation is going
to get worse before it gets better
there are long-term plans being made
worst-case scenario plans knowing that
medical equipment and ventilators are
needed now and possibly for a long time
some will be imported some will be made
here in Canada as companies retool and
ramp up Abigail Beeman has our top story
tonight Quebec is burning through
equipment ten times faster than usual a
dire situation for the province with the
most kovat 19 cases for some equipment
we have only for three to seven days we
have been able to cover all our needs up
until this point and expect to be able
to cover our needs for medical equipment
in the in the foreseeable future the
Prime Minister pledged two billion
dollars and says equipment will arrive
in the coming weeks
details on overall need and rollout are
slim the federal government has secured
157 million masks and sixty million n95
masks delivery for those and ventilators
begins this week
Ottawa ordered fifteen hundred and
seventy ventilators from Canada and
abroad and is working to find at least
4,000 more they've ordered more test
kits - but aren't saying how many even
though Canada is actually testing quite
a lot of people we want to do more as an
absolutely critical area this emergency
physician started a petition calling for
a warlike effort and says today's
announcement comes late on your hair and
that sort of thing we're begging Ottawa
has been in touch with more than 3000
companies that want to help and today
announced contracts with three of them
for some of the masks ventilators and
test kits daily inquiries from other
countries around the world and large
corporations around the world so we're
proud of Canadian so we're definitely
prioritizing Canada and that is why the
Prime Minister stresses domestic
production is so important while Canada
is also looking to find equipment all
over the world the problem is so is
everyone else
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa here's
a look at cases in Canada right now and
this is confirmed cases we know not
everyone with symptoms is being tested
and there's a backlog on tests in places
like Ontario more than 8,600 people are
now confirmed to have kovat 19 in Canada
Quebec has the most people with the
virus more than 4,100 known cases
Ontario is second nearly 2,000 cases and
in BC more than 1000 people have now
tested positive more than 100 people
have now died of the virus in Canada
those are not just statistics those are
in
jool people are now being mourned by
loved ones and many lived in long-term
care homes at least three more people
have died in one Ontario nursing home
the Pinecrest nursing home in Bobcaygeon
has been badly hit twelve residents
there have died so is a volunteer who
worked at the home many of the remaining
residents are sick and at least 24
workers have tested positive each time
we leave our homes we increase the risk
of spreading this virus and risk making
someone so sick they die Canada's chief
Public Health Officer outlined who she
is most concerned about right now our
greatest concern at the moment relate to
the introduction and spread of the virus
and in closed settings where vulnerable
people result we currently have a number
of ongoing outbreaks in long-term care
homes cases and First Nations and Inuit
communities and the corrections facility
to First Nations communities in Manitoba
are asking the military for help to
prepare for an outbreak there in a
letter to the Defense Minister they're
requesting a military hospital be built
in their territories for testing and
quarantine when the first cases are
confirmed and here's one indicator of
how long we could be in this Toronto
Mayor John Tory today canceled all
public events in that city until the end
of June that includes all cultural
events concerts and festivals including
Pride weekend this is not an easy
decision to make while we treasure many
of these events and the important
contribution they make to life in our
city protecting the health and safety of
Toronto residents has to be our primary
concern right now it is April 1st
tomorrow the day most people individuals
and businesses have to pay their rent
and if you've got no money coming in you
are in trouble there are some government
measures to help Ontario for example is
given landlords a six month deferral on
mortgages and it's frozen rents and
halted evictions Mike Joel a looks at
what else is being done to keep people
and companies in place LG F G fashion
houses business is all about personal
touch but in a pandemic bespoke suits
are the first to go we saw about four
hundred and
appointments fall off the calendar in
one week founded in Calgary there now
global operating in 20 countries with
income dried up they're now trying to
save jobs by offloading physical office
space there are a couple offices
obviously that we are basically just
trying to buy ourselves out of but right
now the landlord's are not are not very
complicit because they're having a hard
time business throughout Canada is
suffering and the accompanying layoffs
have left many individuals and
businesses struggling to make rent
and while some landlords have agreed to
deferred payments one of the largest in
the country
smart centers told tenants in an email
sent last week obtained by global news
that rent relief requests are premature
and that they respectfully request the
tenant honor its lease smart center says
it is deferring payments on a
case-by-case basis and that email no
longer applies you know eons ago in the
scheme of this situation we want them to
be in business when the system over we
all want them to be they are the in
other ways the heart and soul of our
communities it should be noted that
smart centers isn't the bad guy here
they too have bills to pay so who has to
shoulder this financial burden is it the
banks the landlords the tenants or even
the government bailing them all out
France has taken the most aggressive
approach out there by suspending rent
and utility payments for small
businesses which economists say will set
them up for eventually recovering faster
than other countries so what model
should Canada adopt the federal
government is offering wage subsidies
and small loans that are interest-free
for a year which restaurant owners argue
puts too much of the burden on them on
the other end of the spectrum a group
calling itself safe hospitality is
pushing for loan forgiveness economists
say nobody is going to come out of this
unscathed I mean this is gonna be hard
on everyone but I don't think it's just
the government I think all the players
involved in the system from landlords
and even to banks may have to look at
forgoing some of the very strict rules
they have
people paying things on time and they
better figure it out soon because the
rent is due
microlight global news Toronto the only
thing that keeps businesses that are
still open operational or truck drivers
and delivery drivers they spend their
days on the road and now many say they
can't find a place to use the washroom
today Ontario's premier had a message
for businesses and gas stations to have
a heart and open their washrooms to
truck drivers clean your washrooms let
them use your washrooms because if it
wasn't for the truckers you wouldn't
even be open you wouldn't even have any
items in your stores to the self it
wasn't for these same people that are
hauling goods from one end of our
country to the other and getting the
essential services through so have a
heart those two cruise ships with nearly
250 Canadians on board have now reached
Miami after they were stranded at sea
for two weeks the US Coast Guard is now
working with Holland America to plan
when they can dock the Zaandam is
infected with kovat 19 for people on
board died and nearly 200 others are
sick with flu-like symptoms including at
least nine who have tested positive for
the virus its sister ship the Rotterdam
is carrying what we believe are healthy
passengers but neither ship has been
able to dock in Florida because of fears
the passengers would be a drain on
already scarce medical resources in that
state to try to get a handle on what to
plan for epidemiologists do what's
called disease modelling projecting how
this infection might spread and the
projections in the u.s. are grim it has
now surpassed China in the number of
people who have died from Cove in 19 New
York City is overwhelmed and the numbers
are soaring elsewhere to Jackson
prosecco joins me from Washington
Jackson the White House laid out a
sobering look at the models for when
this might peak in that country what can
you tell us Donna they're talking about
one hundred thousand to two hundred and
forty thousand fatalities in this
country if full social distancing
measures are brought into place at the
peak of the epidemic in a few weeks time
they could see 2,200 deaths per day in
this country a short time ago President
Trump emerged
urged Americans to prepare for a
difficult few weeks ahead I want every
American to be prepared for the hard
days that lie ahead we're gonna go
through a very tough two weeks you're
gonna start seeing some real light at
the end of the tunnel but this is going
to be a very painful very very painful
two weeks 100,000 fatalities is the
best-case scenario at this point but
getting there is going to be exceedingly
difficult as States fight each other for
vital supplies and they're running into
real roadblocks New York offers a grim
preview of what's to come across the
United States this is the same outside
my job right now an endless line of
ambulances waits to drop patients at
hospitals the number of dead and
infected continues to grow at an
alarming rate 1,200 members of New York
City's police force are confirmed to
have the virus
New York's governor announced his own
brother CNN news anchor Chris Cuomo was
one of nearly 10,000 New Yorkers to test
positive in the last day it is the great
equalizer I don't care how smart power
rich how powerful you think you are
States now find themselves locked in a
bidding war for scarce supplies
competing against each other as they all
face the same problem New Orleans says
it will run out of ventilators in just
six days
86 percent of our patients Florida New
Jersey and Michigan have reported
worsening outbreaks of their own Detroit
is quickly becoming a hot spot this
virus is gonna continue to grow in the
city for a period of weeks three out of
four Americans are under orders to stay
at home residents of Washington DC face
the threat of fines or jail time if they
venture out for any non-essential reason
while at sea 4,000 American sailors are
trapped in place on board an aircraft
carrier where 200 have tested positive
the ship's captain sent a memo to the
Pentagon pleading for a plan to help his
crew
despite those sobering predictions the
White House has not strengthened its
guidelines for Americans when it comes
to social distancing they have extended
them for a full 30 days but they're
still voluntary and some states are
still not participating Donna not a good
sign Jackson Prosecco and Washington
thanks Africa's largest city now under
lockdown coming up how nigeria is faring
during this pandemic Plus forget going
to the dogs
this town is gone to the goats there is
sorrow in Spain as the dead are buried
more than 849 people died of kovat 19
there today alone that's the highest
single day increase in Spain the death
toll is now over 8,000 in the UK more
people died today - than any previous
day 381 deaths were recorded pushing the
total to over 1,700 and new data
suggests the true death toll could be
over 20 percent higher because official
government figures in the UK do not
include people who died at home and in
care homes Africa's largest city is now
locked down Lagos Nigeria a city of 21
million people ground to a halt two
weeks of quarantine have been imposed on
parts of that country there are over a
hundred and thirty confirmed cases of
kovat 19 in Nigeria about 5,300 known
cases across all of Africa still ahead
Alberta
doubles down on its energy investments
big news for the oil and gas sector in
Alberta the stalled Keystone XL pipeline
project is being kick-started the
Alberta government is investing 1.1
billion u.s. dollars in the project TC
Energy formerly TransCanada says that
will cover costs of construction for
this year the 1,900 kilometre pipeline
project first proposed in 2008 would
carry 830,000 barrels of crude a day
from Alberta's oil sands to Nebraska
where it connects with the company's
existing line to the Gulf Coast
Alberta is also giving a 6 billion
dollar loan guarantee so the company can
finance ongoing construction costs
Keystone XL has been subject to all
kinds of legal and environmental
challenges so why restart it now
especially when a barrel of oil costs
about as much as a couple of cups of
coffee
as Heather Eurex West explains Alberta
sees it as an investment in the future
the last few weeks have thrown Canada's
energy sector into turmoil watching oil
prices sink two levels the industry has
never seen before it is as bad as it's
ever been worse than it's ever been it's
too much oil being produced in the world
and as all of us stay at home the demand
for gasoline and jet fuel has really
dropped this week the price of a barrel
of Western Canada selected dipped below
four dollars forcing oil companies to
cut their spending as much as they can
capital budgets been slashed by over six
billion dollars in the last three weeks
in Canada we're seeing a pullback on
anything that companies can do to
maintain cash flow for the time being
the spending cuts have meant more job
losses in a province that has been
struggling with employment since the
last downturn in oil and gas it's why
Alberta's government is now pouring more
than a billion dollars into the
construction of the Keystone XL pipeline
trying to get Albertans working while
the sector weathers this storm this is a
big deal that will create thousands of
jobs it will help Alberta and Canada to
recover more quickly from the brutal
economic impact of the kovat 19 global
recession but energy leaders say more
will be needed as they await details of
the federal government's promised 15
billion dollar bailout you're talking to
the federal government
of pieces around liquidity looking at
what they did for the manufacturing
sector innovate as one of the models
we're talking to them about regulatory
flexibility help needed to ensure small
and medium sized oil companies can make
it through the coming months so they'll
be able to return to business once
global demand rises again Heather your
ex West Global News Calgary next curious
kids our youngest viewers ask Ovid 19
questions well as any parent knows kids
can ask a lot of questions and lately
they've been wanting to know how long
they're going to be stuck at home out of
school and away from friends all over
the past month Global's Jeff sample has
been taking some of your kovin 19
questions straight to the experts and
tonight he's taking questions from kids
Jeff well Donna the Ontario government
just announced its suspending schools in
this province for at least two more
weeks while other provinces such as
Alberta and BC have already closed their
schools indefinitely and that has a lot
of kids asking about this why are pre
playgrounds drill
closed and why am I not able to go back
to school schools really serve as an
incubator where the virus is actively
spreading and that's particularly true
in the case of kovat 19 because
children's symptoms are mostly mild
they're not that sick but then they're
bringing at home and then that's where
this just starts to a multiply bit 19's
germs can survive on plastic like a desk
or play structure for up to three days
so if you do leave the house don't touch
your face even if you get an itch if you
want to pick your nose but what happens
if you do get sick how long does it take
you to get the provirus how do you know
that you have their own awareness
the people seem to have symptoms of
Kaufer a cold or fever
if you're a kid it's important for them
to chat with their parents and of course
parents it's important to have a chat
with your kids so there's no cure for
the corona virus and some people have
recovered how did they recover when
there's no cure when you get sick with
covin 19 your immune system sounds the
alarm and creates antibodies who fight
back hopefully after a few days they
deliver a knockout punch
and they will have at least some form of
community that will make it so they
either don't get it again or if they do
get it again it'll be more mild what's
your name how many minutes are we gonna
be home and how long till we go to our
friends house and grandma's house again
unfortunately medical experts say it's
not a matter of minutes but weeks I do
think that these physical distancing
measures are going to last for at least
another six to eight weeks if not longer
and as for visiting grandma it's
actually your grandparents older people
who are most at risk from this virus so
it's important to do your part to help
keep them safe Donna and find other ways
to reach out Jeff simple thank you Jeff
will continue to consult with experts
and try to answer your questions send
them to your questions at global news CA
and on our website you'll find a special
page dedicated entirely to kovat 19
that's at global news CA / coronavirus
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen all the lockdowns
around the world of trance for in some
cities into ghost towns and in one Welsh
town the goats have sensed an
opportunity
[Music]
these wild goats are taking advantage of
deserted streets roaming on roads and
grazing wherever they feel like it
thanks for watching and take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]